[Music]
this week on
forward hey everyone this week we have a
special interview I did with futurist
and founder of the xprize Peter
diamandis for his podcast moonshots what
is your road map how do we make change
here how do we save uh ourselves from
what's happened in this two- party
system we get into everything from
artificial intelligence to online voting
to Independent nonpartisan primaries and
rank Choice voting if you like the
conversation go check out Peter's
podcast moonshots but first I hope you
enjoyed this fun conversation we had
just a few weeks
[Music]
ago well I don't not sure I want to call
you a politician I want to call you an
entrepreneur I want to call you a change
maker uh in the political realm uh
Andrew Yang Andrew good to see you my
friend oh great to be here Peter and
yeah I'm something of uh I I dislike the
title politician so I I appreciate
you're exempting
me yeah you're you're far more than that
and uh you're a strategist and an
innovator and I'm excited to jump into
it uh as is usual before we dive into a
show let me ask you uh what is your
moonshot most people who uh sat into the
2020 race remember my moonshot was
Universal basic income uh which is
eradicating poverty in our time and
that's still the vision the goal but
I've now identified that there's an
intermediate moonshot which is fixing
American democracy so that it actually
can solve meaningful problems
effectively so doing that first and then
hopefully we can turn back to
eradicating poverty all right well let's
let's jump into both of those moonshots
uh but before we do I've got a question
for you and it's a conversation I've had
going on with a number of AI experts on
this podcast which is the coming us
election 20124 looks like catnip for AI
disruptors uh for deep fakes for people
who want to get in there and sort of
cause trouble what is your thought about
how AI generative AI is going to start
playing a role in the next 18
months yeah I I think it's going to be a
big part of this cycle and not in a good
way and I try to explain to folks look U
imagine if the incremental cost of uh
video and email a text an image is zero
and I can make those images or videos
true to life convincing and they're
completely made up and fabricated where
you saw even recently there was I think
a a a picture of the Pentagon being on
fire and stock markets moved before any
anyone could say wait a minute that was
AI generated um now you can imagine that
times 100 or a thousand in this next
cycle uh I I'd almost advise people down
the stretch is just turn off your social
media
feed because I I think it's uh going to
be that cacophonous unfortunately I can
I can imagine that I mean I'm
wondering how much democracy is going to
be threatened in the near- term like the
2024 presidential elections Mo goodat
who's been on my podcast a few times who
wrote scary smart calls it patient zero
for the disruptions that we're going to
see from AI now I'm the guy out there
saying AI is the most important
invention ever that's going to help us
solve Humanity's Grand challenges uplift
you know create abundance all those
things but I can imagine patient zero
being the elections and making uh
Cambridge analytica look like uh you
know
kindergarten I can imagine both of those
things too Peter I mean I tell people
look if you want to improve The Human
Condition AI could be the most positive
development in uh in Generations maybe
ever in human memory really uh in terms
of alleviating Alzheimer's and cancer I
know you're working on Aging which is
the
greatest you know the the greatest it's
hard as I can as hard as I know I mean
it's it's fantastic I'm super glad
you're doing it but in in the interim
this 24 cycle could end up being patient
zero do you think that the politicians
out there are ready for this do you
think the the existing parties are are
ready Are they scrambling are they
scared are they in a heightened sense of
oh my God how do we either use this or
defend against this well what one of the
reasons why I don't think you're seeing
much in the way of countermeasures uh or
concerns or precautions or whatnot is
that most political figur
are more like rats in a maze than
anything you know what I mean um like
can we just stop with can we stop with
rats well they there's going out there
and they're thinking okay what do I need
to do to keep my seat to raise this
money to make this person like me to get
this positive press cycle to get this
social media post to you know like get
more likes I mean like that that's where
most people's heads are and the
systemwide problem
of eroding or collapsing trust uh and
integrity of our democracy Fall by the
wayside I mean one of the things that
I'm arguing now is that America's
democracy is actually very very
dysfunctional and has been for quite
some time but if you're uh an existing
political figure your problem is not
fixing the dysfunction your problem is
just fulfilling Your Role within the
maze or within the cage uh I mean one
fact I think most people know know but I
just want to put a fine point on it most
elected officials in DC spend between 30
and 60% of their days Dialing for
Dollars you know so imagine if you had
half your schedule calling rich people
and then the other half the time uh you
know theoretically legislating or or
running around meeting people are
constituents you don't have a lot of
bandwidth left over for trying to
insulate the system from
AI I can imagine that but I bet you
there are forces out there that want to
utilize AI to tilt the next election
cycle um is the US government ready to
call it out when they see it or defend
against it uh do you have you been in
any of those conversations I've been in
rooms with various folks who are making
the case uh to government officials or
the government officials themselves um
we're totally unprepared truthfully um
uh the the current American political
system is reactive not proactive um and
so we're going to go through at least
one cycle of real real damage um before
anything meaningful is done I imagine
that right it's uh we had been talking
about airplanes being used for terrorism
for a long time um and it was 9911 that
got people to change uh Behavior we've
been talking about pandemics for a long
time and uh it was finally coid that God
has to accelerate vaccine development I
I'm afraid that uh we don't take action
until there's a disaster
and the horse is out of the barn yeah um
we're going to be one disaster behind on
this one too I'm sure on the flip side
AI could play a massive role in helping
to educate the electorate on what's
going on I mean my biggest my biggest
problem as a voter here in California is
I go to the polls I look at all of these
you know individuals and uh uh and
what's being voted on and you know I'm
busy I've had had very little time to
get educated on them and getting a clear
answer is really hard and you're
dependent upon these commercials that
you may or may not have seen there's got
to be some mechanism that you know
better generative AI can sort of
position the situations and compare and
contrast them and allow we to make a
decision but is that happening or do
people not want that I would love to
help make that happen uh in the form of
the forward party you're right that most
people are right now um both have too
much information overload and not enough
information simultaneously it's a good
time you show up it's one reason why
what is the main form of political
communication you see it's just
someone's name really they're just
trying to get their name imprinted into
your mind so that when you show up uh
you can vote for them it's very seldom
the political party one of the dirty
secrets in California and the rest of
the country
uh is that most of us don't have a
two-party system you have a onep party
system where you are in California there
is zero suspense I guess I'm guessing um
it's going to be a Democrat and so which
flavor of democrat you're not sure so
you show up and then uh it's going to be
a name you recognize perhaps it's one
reason why at the federal level you have
a 94% re-election rate for incumbents
94% that's that's insane yeah yeah 94%
Congressional incumbent re-election rate
and only a 15 to 20% approval rating of
Congress RIT large so that they've drawn
a completely uncompetitive
unrepresentative system and then told us
hey it's a two-party system you're
competing like they're not in California
you know Democrats run everything they
have three quarters of the legislature
they're having conversations with
themselves um and by the way in
California they're not delivering on
things like homelessness
or uh public safety or education but
then they just Pat you on the head and
say well what are you going to do like
that they're you're stuck with us uh and
if you go to a place like Texas it's the
reverse where the Republicans would be
like what are you going to do so um that
so that there is very very little actual
competition in the system it's one of
the things that we're trying to change I
have to say when you stood on the stage
of a360 and spoke your heart uh I was so
impressed at at what you had to say and
you had standing room only and and your
follow on uh it's nice to hear and I'm
not going to call you a politician a
presidential candidate uh and a a
political entrepreneur uh thinking
logically about this and so one of the
things you know that's important for
people to realize and hopefully you
realize this in gr school is we don't
actually have a de direct democracy we
have a representative democracy and I
assume that's because you know when
America was born the idea of getting
everybody in the country to actually
vote was not viable uh but it is viable
now um can you talk to how is technology
how could technology save uh The
American or democracy American political
system now so the our founding fathers
were not fans of direct democracy uh as
You observe and it wasn't because there
was some uh logistical limitation uh
really they just didn't trust people
honestly they said you know what we're
going to have um this representative uh
system we're going to we're going to
sort it out and you have three branches
and you also had uh these two
legislative bodies one of which was
supposed to be a little bit more close
to the people in the form of the House
of Representatives and then the Senate
was supposed to be more elevated if you
will um and deliberative though uh they
did not Envision uh our Founders the
two- party system um George Washington
famously warned against political
parties on his way out John Adams said
two parties would be a great evil across
the land uh James Madison said you can't
have factions that don't shift uh and
and so you had this representative uh
system that was set up that did not
reckon with the fact that you'd have uh
the domination of these two parties the
way that took place uh and even then the
two parties until the let's call it the'
7s 60s and70s were sort of like vanilla
and french
vanilla they weren't that opposed and if
you know a republican um brought a
Democrat home as their boyfriend or
girlfriend you know the parents were
like
cool you know you were more concerned
about uh let's call it race or religion
than you were party um because the two
parties were not that dissimilar and
then over the last 40 some odd years
then the two parties have started to
peel off
ideologically um and polarize uh in the
way that they have um so you have now
this Urban versus rur
educated versus Le less educated uh
diverse versus more homogeneous Etc like
that these things that that are becoming
more and more entrenched and uh none of
this by the way is in the founding
design like the founding design was look
um we'll have different coalitions we'll
come together we'll come apart we'll do
different things they never imagined
that you'd wind up in these two
increasingly polarized tribes that now
um don't need to deliver for us and this
is why so many Americans are so
frustrated is that with this 94% re
incumbent uh you know incumbent
re-election rate and the fact that 90%
of districts are drawn to be either blue
or red and uncompetitive in the general
uh the big myth in American life is that
our leaders have to please 51% of us to
stay in office it's just not true uh the
reality is they just need they just need
to plate or please um the folks who vote
in either the Democratic or the
Republican primary which is generally
between 10 and uh 14% of people in the
district so if I'm a member of Congress
I just need to Plate the most extreme
folks in my party and then I'm on a
Glide path to
re-election imagine running for
president and wanting to share what you
experienced in a way that's entertaining
edifying and maybe even a little bit
scary that's the last election out in
bookstores now a novel about an
independent presidential candidate a
journalist with a massive story and what
the heck could be our nextlast election
check it out at andrewyang.com
[Music]
what is the road map for fixing
democracy and just to note you know you
have a book coming out called the last
election um right around the time this
episode is is coming out is it on this
subject well the last election is a
piece of fiction actually it's a it's I
I'm trying to drag people into the
message in different ways and so we
decided just to have this political
thriller about an independent
presidential candidate that's Loosely
based on Mark hbin sorry
Mark and then um what happens uh
throughout that election with this uh
new independent candidate how much of
the book how much of the book did chat
GPT write for you um uh unfortunately I
finished the book with my writing
partner before chat GPT really hit the
scene so uh you know kid zero
unfortunately uh the book I wrote about
our political system uh is called
forward notes on the future of our
democracy it's now out on paperback um
so I've written a couple of books on
this subject but I was trying to codify
and lay out what most Americans Sense on
some level it's been fun on uh some
occasions like frankly at abundance 360
where you talk to entrepreneurs leaders
uh
technologists um Builders and then you
say to them hey you know this allergy
you have to politics it's totally
rational and what's irrational is the
setup where um you you have a bunch a
series of fiction that are presented to
the American people about our political
system that after you start digging in
you realize okay they're not true and
then the question is how do you actually
fix it so that that's what I i' I've now
been involved in and I'm happy to say
we're actually making some progress
awesome and I fallen into the camp where
listen talk to me about anything just
not politics right I if I want to fix
something I'm going to start a company
I'm going to go and and work on fixing
it the last thing I want to do is get
involved in politics and I have lost
belief in the political process to fix
problems I believe that entrepreneurs
are individuals who find juicy problems
building you product or service
demonetize democratize it and solve that
problem yeah I I think you are a very
smart and wise man Peter um I spoke to
20 Business Leaders and I actually posed
this question and they were CEOs they
were you know ve very very uh eminent
folks and I said how many of you at some
point in your career are considered
running for political office and a
majority of hands went up because you
know that the these are accomplished
people and then I said how many of you
have now concluded that you should not
run for office because the system is so
irrational you're going to get dragged
through the mud and even on the chance
that you manage to Prevail over the
machine you're not actually going to be
get get anything done anyway and then
they all laugh but then all of their
head go up you know um reasonable people
have just drawn this conclusion based on
evidence because they're smart so the
the it stacked this in the system is
stacked against us I said years ago any
um with due respect to yourself my
friend anyone who wants to run for
president shouldn't be allowed to it
should be a drafted position for some of
the smartest operators in the planet I
totally agree and I also said to that
group of Business Leaders I said I don't
know you all that well but I would put
you all in charge of the country ahead
of the people who are actually running
the country 100 times out of 100 and
they all laughed and they said yeah like
we would too because they they're r
they'd be evidence-based they'd just be
trying to get things done their
motivations would be generally good all
of which doesn't apply to the
current so is there is there a path
forward I mean you know obviously the
the forward party is uh been doing a lot
of the Strategic thinking and we can
talk about what the forward party is uh
I view myself as really a Libertarian
capitalist if I had to if I had to
position myself in some fashion but what
is your road mapap how do we make change
here how do we save uh ourselves from
what's happened in this two party system
thank you Peter I have many friends who
describe themselves the same way what
I'd say is the the whole path is to make
the fiction real now how the heck do you
do that in real life which which fiction
real the fiction is that our leaders
need to make 51% of us happy and deliver
for us in order to keep their jobs
instead of just the the 10 to 12% in the
primary electorate in the wings with
their 94% uh reelect rate so how the
heck do you make the fiction real so it
turns out that because our founding
fathers did not like political parties
there's not a word about being a
Democrat or Republican anywhere in the
Constitution and all of the party
mechanisms are established at the state
level it's all made up all right now if
you wanted to you could change those
mechanics in each state and in 25 States
you could do so via ballot initiative
where 50.1% of the people in that state
decide to they could for example get rid
of party primaries in that state now as
I'm saying this it sounds made up and
impossible just understand what this
means it means any candidate who wants
to run independent of the party they all
go up against each other at the same
time yes imagine all Party primary where
you run as a Libertarian I run as
forward party there are two Democrats
there are three Republicans what have
you and we all line up and make our case
to the folks in that state and then the
top four of us get through to a general
election and then the winner is chosen
be a rank Choice voting now this is not
a thought experiment everything I just
described happened you mean you mean a
democratic process
oh yeah no yeah I mean a democratic
process now um everything I just
described happened in Alaska in 2022
where in
2020 a majority of alaskans voted to get
rid of the party primaries and said you
know what for any Statewide race it's
all candidates in the same Mega primary
and then the top four get through and
are put through rank Choice voting to
determine who wins now in 2022 when you
had a genuinely Democratic process you
know what happened Sarah Palin lost to a
woman named Mary peltola who in the
conventional system would not have won
but Mary pela because of rank Choy
voting managed to win by I think four
points in the second or third round of
voting same principle a woman named Lisa
marowski who's the incumbent one despite
voting to impeach Donald Trump and she
managed to defeat a trump endorsed
Challenger named Kelly shab Baka
because a majority of Alaskan said look
maybe I didn't love her decision on that
one but I gen generally think Lisa
marowski is a reasonable person in a
conventional system where Lisa marowski
and Kelly Shabaka just went through a
Republican primary Shabaka wins easily
uh Lisa marowski's approval rating among
Alaskan Republicans went down to 8% when
she voted to impeach Trump but there's
no Republican primary anymore by the way
half a dozen US senators went to
marowski on the senate floor and said we
Envy you so much you don't have a
primary imagine if all of the senators
in the US all of a sudden could say no
to their party's base and instead would
go to their constituents and say I'm
going to make 51% of you happy our
decision-mak policy improves just like
that so so what enabled Alaska to put
that ballot forward and get it supported
I would assume that the you know the
political parties would have fought it
tooth and nail that is right Peter but
it turns out that Alaska is a very cheap
media State you and I could be on
Alaskan TV tomorrow if we so desired uh
so the ballot initiative in Alaska to
get rid of the primaries cost $6
million the same balot I know it's the
best bargain in history I mean you get
you get Sarah Palin out you get Kelly
shabbach out and it's Evergreen it's not
like you have to spend $6 million every
cycle you spend $6 million just to get
rid of the primaries I I love alas
Frontier state right the the frontier
mindset is still there and uh good for
them to lead the way but but I I want to
paint this picture because it's so
important so then the same principle
applied in Nevada now a lot of people
listening to this think okay Alaska's
weird Nevada's a little bit more normal
and like you said the two parties
decided to fight this ballot initiative
tooth and nail but the winning
advertisement in Nevada was a military
veteran looking at the camera saying I
went overseas to defend our country for
years I came back and I can't vote in
our primaries and I don't think that's
right why couldn't he vote in the
primary because you need to be a
registered democrat or republican to
participate in either primary and he was
an independent like 50% of military
veterans and like at this point 50% of
Americans functionally so that ad went
out on Nevada TV and millions of Nevada
and saw it and were like that guy should
be able to vote so the Democratic party
came out against it the party came out
against it but 53% of nevadan said that
guy should be able to vote and I should
be able to vote for whomever I want in
an allp Party primary so what we're
doing is we're going state to state and
then flipping over the primary system
because if you put it in front of the
American people of course they want to
be able to vote for whomever they want
the fact that our tax dollars are
subsidizing these party primaries is
ridiculous it's distorting everything
and the only people it's good for are
the people embedded in the machine who
don't want to have to actually submit
themselves to us I I love it it's got my
vote for sure I mean it's like wait this
sounds really
logical it's logical and if someone
wants to dig into this the progenitors
of this set of reforms it's Michael
Porter who's a Harvard Business School
uh professor and Godfather of management
consulting and a woman named Katherine
Gail they co-authored a book called the
politics industry that said you you know
why we're seeing our political system
flail and fumble this way it's because
of bad incentives in the system and the
way to fix the incentives is to get rid
of the party primaries and here's how to
do it so the ballot initiative in Nevada
cost 17 million which is more than the
six in Alaska if someone were to say to
me how much does it cost to fix American
democracy I would say approximately $200
million which in our world Peter is a
very man
that's yeah in in the in the context of
a system where we're going to spend
billion beating each other up and hating
each other in 2024 just one of the
Forbes 500 individuals listening here
please just you know plug please get in
touch with with me uh you can grab me on
uh socials Andrew Yang Peter has my
number an email um but how does the $200
million fixed democracy check it out you
run the same ballot initiative that won
in Alaska and Nevada in 10 states it
fails in five of them but that's okay
you succeed in five and then you
liberate 10 US senators to do whatever
they think is best and not be enthral to
their parties on either side that
changes the nature of American politics
it's no dead that and that's very very
real that's very very
doable hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you that's huge and that's again it's
the first piece of clear and logical
thinking I've heard in a while so thank
you for making that um thank you for
explaining that what's next on a road
map where do we you know okay we pull
that off
what's the next step in in heading us
towards a true democracy so I concluded
all of these things now about 18 months
ago and so I've been running around with
forward uh now let's say that we pull
off what I'm describing we get rid of
the party primaries in five states 10 US
senators all of a sudden
lucid and
clear with lots of time on their no I
mean it's pretty wild like you know that
they would they'd be like hey all of a
sudden I'm I'm they their own they have
their own opinion yeah yes they have
their own opinion and in the other 25
states you have Mayors and County
Executives and city council members and
occasional members of Congress also
throwing off the Yoke of the false blue
versus red and saying I'm also part of
this new positive independent political
movement forward now you fast forward to
the next cycle this is the great
frustration that you and many others
share is that we might be faced with a
Joe Biden Donald Trump rematch in 2024
God forbid uh and it's patently
ridiculous by the by the way uh what do
you put the odds that that could happen
or would
happen uh the odds are very high um
because Trump will probably win the
Republican nomination despite his legal
troubles he's up 20 some odd points Joe
Biden by all accounts is running again
there's some rumor that he's going to
step aside at the last minute next year
but you know uh like I'll believe it
when I see it kind of thing um so the
Biden Trump rematch combined age 160 is
very much on top nothing against you
know folks of an advanced age but these
are not the octogenarians you
want this couple others I know I'd be
fed with but but these are not the two
before age reversal has been implemented
yes yes you know like what
what these aren't the 80-year-olds you
want anyway um so but it's just a clear
emblem of how bizarre and dysfunctional
a two-party system is that in a country
of 330 million people those will be the
choices I mean gosh Peter like I was
with you at abundance 360 and I could
almost just throw a rock and just take
any of the people that the rock hits and
say you'd be a better choice than Joe or
Donald Trump I believe so so if we get
presented with this Choice many
Americans are going to be looking for an
alternative um now I my or organization
forward what we'll be doing is we'll be
trying to organize swing voters in
Wisconsin Pennsylvania Arizona Georgia
Nevada swing gen genuinely independent
swing voters and say we're going to go
with whichever party is on board with
getting rid of the party primaries and
implementing rank Choice voting and
reforming uh the system itself um so
that's our project for 2024 but I'm
going to project in the not so distant
future let's call it 2028 Okay so
imagine there was uh an independent
presidential primary where it's uh Mark
cubin The Rock
Me Oprah Matthew MCC Justin
Amash uh Liz Cheney Adam kininger
whoever your favorite figures are I
don't know if you want to throw someone
into this mix Peter if I miss someone
like is this is this they have to agree
or they being
drafted uh either for the sake maybe
maybe we'll throw Tony Robbins and Elon
into the mix too holy cow so Elon
unfortunately is not born in the US so
there's like but but Tony Robbins all
right jeffz you know Jeff Jeff's SCU uh
you know he's he's got the Washington
Post he's building Rockets you know he's
got a you know he's got to be something
you he's going to go do let's throw Tony
and Jeff into the mix sure and we can
all vote in this primary on our
smartphones say I like Tony I like
Andrew I like Mark Cuban and then our
vote is verified via a personalized QR
code that gets sent to our mailing
address you scan it congratulations your
vote has been verified millions of
Americans are participating in actual
democracy and then the Legacy parties
would be left saying no none of that is
real what is real is waiting to hear
what 6% of Iowans think in February and
then millions of Californians and New
Yorkers and everyone else would be like
wait a minute that makes zero sense I
don't give a what Ians think any
other time why am I carrying this time
or no offense to anyone cuz I love you
all but like South Carolina or new I
mean you could just like throw whatever
the heck the early basket of States I
mean I went through this process only
6.5% of Ians participated in the
Democratic caucus I was a part of it's
probably going to be a not that much
higher percentage of Ians in this
Republican caucus so let me get this
straight um there's a process by which
you raise is above some threshold and I
don't care if you're the Kardashians or
whomever if if you want to run for
president what would be the criteria for
getting yourself on this digital ballot
this is so fun Peter because those 20
people your 20 people who M most of them
know that if they ran for president as a
Democrat or Republican it would be
miserable you know that they would get
shived the same way that we've seen
let's call it Mike Bloomberg get shived
or or whomever um but if you got to run
in this independent primary then you
could genuinely make your case uh you
could positive there's not a machine
trying to oppress you at every turn and
Real Americans could get behind you and
and vote for you in real time so The
Wonder of this is that a political party
can design its nomination process
however it wants the Democrat and
Republican party have chosen to design
it in a particularly anachronistic
nonsensical way not because they think
it's smart but mainly because of inertia
and they prefer to control it gives them
control of course it's just control
right and part of that control has been
the media where if you see how the media
covers various candidates and I was a
part of this too in my book forward they
very much have their thumb on the scale
for certain candidates uh and so that's
how they they they try to make sure that
the their chosen candidate or candidates
win um but now all of that's falling
apart and so what is the new process
that replaces it all there is we all we
you and I both know and everyone
listening to this know the tech for what
I'm describing is completely mature a
political party can again nominate
however it wants the only things that
you need are number one some
heavyweights who are willing to run in
this kind of process and number two
ballot access in all 50 states now the
the ballot access I is if you had to put
a price tag on it maybe it cost you
about $50 million now the forward party
already has legal recognition in about
eight states we're kind of marching
towards uh uh 20 by the end of 2024
let's say so this is the
infrastructure so that reasonable
candidates actually can submit
themselves genu genuinely to the
American people without the massive
gatekeeping function of the Legacy
parties that just want to keep everyone
out I love it's it's the way it should
be I mean we do uh you know we move
millions of dollars and some people
billions of dollars on bitcoin on your
smartphone um you have all of your
functions and life in verified fashion
why not vote um that's brilliant now
you've mentioned Mark cubin three times
have you spoken to him about this I I I
have and he is one my uh one of my top
draft picks uh for this endeavor um if
if you don't know check out's Cost Plus
drugs mean he's yeah I do know the
company it's to yeah great stuff love
you mark yeah so listen I think I think
this is a fantastic idea um and you know
at this point hopefully it's not just to
being about a popular individual it's
hopefully going to be being popular and
being intelligent and having good
policies I mean why do people why do
people say this wouldn't work I mean I
would imagine people say well a populist
politician uh or president doesn't have
the experience uh that's needed to run
uh they have to rise through the ranks
of you know local state and and uh
Federal politics most people have not
dug into it even that deeply Peter
honestly um most people just knee-jerk
think well uh third party hopeless Ross
perau Ralph nater uh Jill Stein etc etc
now if they looked at the numbers they
would see that now 49% of Americans
self-identify as Independence almost
twice as what identify as democrat or
republican that this kind of Internet
voting is now very very doable and
natural for Americans in a way it was
not even in the
90s uh but their
reservations um are not the ones you
just cited because most Americans are
fed up they would happily take a
reasonable human that is not of the
machine at this point they just don't
think it's possible um because of the
conditioning particularly from the media
that you must choose either column A or
column B and nothing else
exists yeah I think people don't realize
the influence the media has on politics
um and we for I don't know what reason
think of the media as still concr you
know what's his name um Walter con
Walter concrate yes I mean it's
independent it's truthful it's you know
representing you know truth in the
American way but that's anything but
Well I this podcast I'll probably get a
similar audience to you know one of the
major cable channels you
know well so you know and a much cooler
audience I will say a much better
audience most people watching this are
not you know yeah they're entrepreneurs
they care about changing the world and
uh they want you know the mindset is
let's find out where we can make things
things better you know up and to the
right you know it's interesting right
because maybe it's going to be Twitter
maybe it's going to be Google maybe it's
going to be some other platform but the
platforms exist um for full up
verification and uh to reach everybody
in America well you talk about the media
I mean I think that's what motivated
Elon and um buying uh Twitter SLX now is
that he thought you know this is going
to be one way I can actually uh try to
improve the nature of the messages that
are getting out um but what I'm
describing it's right there for us man
um the the fun thing is you can imagine
who would run and a lot more excellent
people would run if they thought they
would be treated fairly do you think
think the US people would change the
rules about being born in the US if Elon
wanted to run I don't know but I'd
certainly love to test that proposition
out I was with Arnold Schwarzenegger not
that long ago I said you should test
that proposition out but here's one of
the the fun things Peter let's say that
this independent primary does come to
pass let's I I'm just just going to
speak for myself if I were part of it
and let's say I lose to I I'll keep
using Mark just as my example sure um I
would then endorse Mark and say hey man
like let me go campaign for you around
the country and you could campaign
anywhere you'd end up with a team of a
dozen high-powered surrogates and
something of an Administration or a
cabinet in waiting and the American
people would be like that crew is is a
crew I would trust and prefer much much
more than the the current freaking
panoply of you know frankly mostly
second
Raiders I I I love it you're right once
it flips you've got you know uh 30
incredible uh influencers ready to back
the independent car uh candidate yeah
that that's the vision man it's going to
be the Avengers of rationality and uh
you know true progress and so can people
have you written up these ideas in a
concrete fashion someplace so if you go
to forward party uh that this is the
movement um I have not written up the um
independent primary plan though there
have been frankly versions of this that
have uh been written up I I'm going to
be excited to to get energy behind the
2028 plan um one reason why I'm not
hammering that that hard is because we
are stuck in 2024 right now to our
earlier conversation and so we're trying
to organize independent swing voters in
swing states to try and keep the current
thing from collapsing I love it and and
this in fact is the digitization and
democratization of democracy in this
regard right it's making the fiction
real Peter and and to the way you
described me before uh my dad was a PhD
in physics at of Berkeley so when I saw
Oppenheimer I was like oh my gosh this
is like the freaking Family Tree in
action my my brother's named after
Ernest Lawrence nice uh the who's Josh
har character um but I I'm a a deeply
flawed politician shall we say in that I
I just want to try and make things work
better uh I would prefer to be doing
something
else very frankly mean I'm like you
where you also are trying to solve
problems and you've wisely said you know
what I'm going to solve the problems
that are solvable through
entrepreneurship and the private sector
for better for worse uh the problems I
started getting animated about like
poverty um were things that I thought
needed the public sector uh to to um um
solve and then now I've gotten um very
deep into the okay how the heck do you
build a functional public
sector this podcast is sponsored by
Helix sleep it's a pretty short list of
things you can do that are going to make
you happier healthier more energetic
more productive every single day you
know what's on that list getting the
right freaking mattress and what's the
right mattress for you if you go to
Helix sleep you take their personalized
sleep quiz and they will send you one of
20 unique mattresses made for you and
you alone well not you and you alone
like 5% of people do the math for 100
night free trial you can sleep on this
thing for 3 months it will keep you cool
don't just take my word for it my kids
seek out this mattress in the house it's
the number one rated mattress picked by
GQ and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now Andrew let's flip to your second
moonshot which is the idea of universal
basic income um so uh the idea just to
lay it out as I understand it and I
welcome your uh your modification here
is as Ai and Robotics and other
exponentials 3D printing arvr blockchain
start to disrupt the job markets and
people uh lose their jobs to technology
um that we need to do a few things one
of them is going to be to to help uh
level up those individuals upscale them
to better skills but potentially at
least in the interim is give them
reliable income uh a universal basic
income that allows them to you know put
food on the table get insurance um not
feel panicked uh perhaps get a better
education perhaps invest in whatever
Tech they need to start a small business
uh and it's about human dignity to a
large degree um and getting rid of fear
because there going to be a lot of fear
as AI steps in in a bigger way in the
next uh few years um I'll say one more
thing and then this is your platform and
you did a huge amount to I don't say
necessarily popularize but educate
people about Universal basic income
which I'm I'm grateful for um the other
thing I wanted to mention is uh it is
something that not a
theoretical uh concept it's been
implemented and tested and uh and
studied uh over dozens if not hundreds
of experiments both in the United States
and around the world so that's my setup
for it and I want people to understand
it's uh this is coming because we need a
counterveiling force to the fear that
people have about potentially losing
their jobs well I I love the way you
frame that Peter the the way I describe
it is that you have have a mindset of
abundance and possibility and optimism
and Entrepreneurship and then you have a
mindset of scarcity fear Us Versus Them
xenophobia uh uh and negativity towards
technology honestly and so which of
these things is winning which of these
is going to win um I think you'd be
hardpressed to say that
Nationwide the mindset of optimism and
possibility is winning it's definitely
winning at abundance through 360 which
was a
blast like over there and it's like I
was uplifted because here are people who
are literally building the the future
but then you know you drive a few hours
in any direction and you wind up at like
a let's say a different mindset um and
so the the question is how do we help
people transition there are a lot of
very smart folks who are deep in AI
who've also been um studying the effects
of Ubi or cash relief programs and one
of the the things I think is going to
appeal to folks uh like you is that
right now we have the worst of all
worlds where we're spending so much
money and energy on dysfunctional
administration of programs that are
really punitive and dehumanizing I spoke
to thousands of Americans who are on
various Aid programs and the single
biggest thing that motivates them is
fear they are scared stiff of losing
their benefits there was a woman in Iowa
who said to me
uh I would like to volunteer for my
local nonprofit but I'm scared to
because I'm on disability and I'm afraid
that if someone saw that I could
volunteer they take my money away yeah
and so you listen to that story and you
think my gosh like what have we done
where This Woman's getting the money but
instead of using the money to live a
better life she's staying in because
she's afraid of being seen as
able-bodied I mean like that that's
what's happening right now for millions
and millions of Americans where we've
set up this unfeeling machine above them
that they do not trust at all by the way
and said hey your uh subsistence is
going to be relying upon your staying on
the good side of this bureaucracy and if
you fill out the form wrong we're going
to pull the rug out from under you I
mean like I I i' I've spoken to military
vets who are in this boat I've spoken to
so many Americans and it it's uh we can
do better let's say yeah sent me an
article uh which framed it as insecurity
versus uh inequality as the issue people
are facing they don't feel secure they
do not feel secure in the in the least
and if we can change that then we have a
much better chance of building a society
where if someone else makes some rapid
Advance you look at it and say oh good
like may maybe that's good for me in
some way right now unfortunately it's
more like like look at that jerk over
there who's doing well like you know um
uh like I'm not seeing any of that so
you've studied this um if you had to uh
you know most people say listen if
you're sending people 500 bucks a month
it's going to be used for beer on
Netflix and it's a waste of money for
God's sakes why are you going to spend
my tax money to do that uh how do you
respond to that what's the data show
well the the the data shows that people
tend to spend the money
on uh food fuel shelter books for their
kids uh activities for their kids uh and
the biggest example of that data set was
the enhanced child tax credit that was
implemented in 20120 and
2021 yeah in the US where it lifted
millions of American kids out of poverty
and 130 economists who looked at it said
we should keep doing this because the
money is getting used very very
effective effectively uh and uh American
politics being what it is we then pulled
the plug on that even though there were
so many uh literally there were Nobel
laurates saying this is the best thing
we've done in a generation to alleviate
poverty U but the data is there for
anyone to find um you also saw saw saw
decreases in things like domestic
violence child abuse uh I mean if you
put a little bit of money into people's
hands you talked about the data Peter
there was one study I found very very
compelling out of an Indian tribe in
North Carolina where One Tribe started
uh giving people a certain amount of
money because they had a casino honestly
there was another tribe that I've got
I've got it here it's the Eastern uh
band of Cherokee Indians Casino dividend
in North
Carolina uh and giving them no strings
attached between 4,000 and 6,000 per
year is that particular one and what
results and you probably have it there
that um you had the kids uh learn better
and their even their personalities
became uh more conscientious more
trusting they were improved education
mental health decrease in addiction and
crime yeah yeah and by the way if you
wound up with people who do turn to
crime and drugs we end up paying for
that too in ways big and small I mean
like the we're spending $ 30 to
$50,000 per individual per year who is
homeless or incarcerated uh in our
country so if it hits our institutions
it's a lot more expensive than that
$46,000 that those uh kids got yeah lest
you think that this is a a new idea I'm
just going to Rattle off here the
research that my producer Nick did you
know um we've seen this in Alaska since
1982 uh Alaska's had uh their their fund
funded by uh by oil I mentioned North
Carolina we've had experiments in New
Jersey uh Pennsylvania Iowa North
Carolina Seattle Denver Gary Indiana a
number is a big study done in Stockton
uh California uh Canada uh England
Brazil Germany Spain the Netherlands has
done a number
Finland uh Iran Kenya uh Namibia India
China um so I mean this has been done
hundreds of times and as I read through
the details here it's
consistent that this investment has
super positive outcomes I haven't read
any place where it's been a had negative
outcomes or a waste of money yeah it
it's much more effective than frankly um
starting up a new bureaucracy and then
saying hey guys uh improve the lives of
people that are not you um one of the
organizations in this space that some
people might have heard of is give
directly which is it transfers money
directly to people in developing
countries uh now there's probably some
skepticism among your audience uh
rightly so of kind of a nonprofit
industrial complex or an NGO industrial
complex um there's probably that
mistrust when it comes to certain
government bureaucracies that are
terrible at uh administering benefits in
a like a frankly a sane way this skips
the middleman uh and gets the resources
to where actually do good yeah and I
I've I've been a donor to give directly
I think it's a uh it's a brilliant uh
you know super low overhead um minimized
overhead U process on a personal level
Peter the way that you and I do this
probably is we just tip really well uh
you know because you're around someone
it's like hey this is going to be dollar
for
dollar and it's such a beautiful thing
when when someone unexpectedly gets a a
large tip and you know for that evening
that moment you've changed their life
yeah it's a great great feeling I highly
recommend it yeah yeah uh so the
question becomes where does this money
come from uh you know can we afford it
and I'd like to play a few a few
conversational games here you know I
remember Jeff Bezos and a few other
folks said well if we're going to start
to see technological displacement of
jobs and a robot takes you know a house
cleaning job or a robot takes a factory
working job or an AI takes a physician's
job why don't we just tax that robot
and that AI uh for that work it's being
done and then use that tax base to fund
a Ubi program does that make sense I
think taxing AI makes a lot of sense uh
I think um the practice of it might be a
little bit
trickier uh the where the money comes
from for starters I I don't know what
people are going to receive this so our
data right now is worth hundreds of
billions of dollars a year um to various
companies your data is going to be worth
more than others
Peter thanks um but we're not seeing a
dime of that so uh one of the proposals
I had was look there should be a data
dividend where I'm not one to hold back
uh certain forms of development but if
you're going to be buying and selling my
data uh maybe I should see what's going
on and get it cut and you know and and
um that could be the start of multi
hundred of billions of dollars uh type
measure uh AI itself um could also and
one of the examples I use is that there
are 2 million Americans who work at call
centers still and let's say that AI is
going to be able to do that job pretty
soon how much do those 2 million
Americans pay in taxes right now I'm
going to guess that they do pay taxes
and then the question is will the tech
company that uses the AI pay anywhere
near that level in taxes history
suggests it will not and so you'll wind
up replacing taxpaying humans with AI
that um we might not see that kind of
revenue from unless we change the system
you know I've had this conversation with
Elon and we've been trying to go back
and forth on when we're going to do
another podcast together on the subject
of abundance and you know his first
reaction is yes we're going to have full
up abundance post AGI right and I get
that you know uh once we have artificial
general intelligence which leads rapid
to artificial super intelligence and
let's put away the dystopian scenarios
the Terminator and we have ai uh we're
heading towards what I would call
technological socialism um you know
being a good uh you know capitalist
entrepreneur the term socialism and
communism sort of like you know are
knives into but technological socialism
is an idea where technology is taking
care of you and uh it's what will happen
right AI your best physician in the
world will be an AI your best
diagnostician your your best surgeon
will be an AI and a robot and those
things will rapidly demonetize toward
zero cost your best educator we saw this
with with salul Khan who's a real hero
as you had said on stage yeah um he is a
her I had dinner with Sal last month and
uh um what a privilege yeah he's such a
sweet man and a brilliant
entrepreneur um and so the things that
we spend a large amount of money on
today we spend a disproportionate amount
on Healthcare and education a lot of
Americans are nodding right now
Peter well and and what we're going to
see is the very best Healthcare and the
very best education is eventually going
to be free because it's going to be
delivered by these uh these AI or AGI
systems right it's the cost of
electricity and so that's going to be a
significant I mean if there a cost of
living what we spend our money on we
spend our money on Health on education
on Transportation eventually an
autonomous Uber will be four times
cheaper than owning a car and if you
don't need to live in downtown Manhattan
or downtown Boston uh because your job
is there because you can commute via
Zoom or because you can commute in a
autonomous Uber back and forth and the
hour of travel time is usable then you
can live someplace where the real estate
is four times cheaper you know and still
you have a beautiful backyard so we're
heading towards a world of mass massive
de uh
demonetization I think and efficiency of
our time so I think the cost of living
should go down while the standards of
living go up do I have it wrong in any
way in your mind I love the vision and I
agree with the mega Trends um the
problems are twofold number one is the
regulatory problem and this is where the
public sector comes back in let's say I
invented AI that could do the job of a
surgeon tomorrow yes you wouldn't see
that happen in hospitals because the
surgeons would just Lobby the
legislators and say hey it's got to be a
human surgeon uh or at a minimum it's
got to be a human surgeon advising the
AI
overseeing the the a so there's this
regulatory capture that's going to make
it uh rough there are certain sectors
and I'm going to use my call center
worker example where legislators aren't
going to give a about them you know
they don't have a
Lobby so so so there you'll see it uh go
very rapidly it's one reason why this
political reform is so important is
because there's going to be a race
toward uh regulatory protection it's
like who who's going to be uh viewed as
like oh you know indispensable human
worker like can't replace you um and the
AMA by by by the way why do we have a
physician shortage in the US of humans I
mean which is one of the reasons why
AI doctors will be such a massive value
ad it's because of the American Medical
Association artificially keeping the
number of doctors low um because they
they didn't want I just thought people
got smarter people got smarter and
realized they don't want to actually
spend four years in medical school five
six seven years internship residency
come out such massive debt just at the
time that AI is going to take their job
so that's why uh no no because if you
think about it there are all of these
folks who are below the line in terms of
applying to medical school uh you know
I'm I'm I'll make an insert Asian joke
here
anyway where that there's been an
artificially curved Supply and then you
know that uh those professionals are
going to Lobby very very furiously and
it's not just the doctors themselves you
see it with certain device manufacturers
where do you know Dean Cayman by chance
I I was with him for dinner at his home
in New Hampshire on Friday night yes oh
my gosh all right so so Dean told me a
story might have told you to where he
invented a portable dialysis machine
which would improve people's standard of
living dramatically but then the folks
who profit from inpatient dialysis said
no no no that's not
safe and their their motivation was
obviously that they make a whole lot
more money yeah it's actually evil it's
actually evil it's evil there there's a
lot of evil going on in this system
because people are making money off of
the inefficiency and they will fight
fight fight to keep the inefficiency
because that's their business now so uh
so the future you're describing is the
future that would be happening in the
absence of this regulatory capture uh
and but there are going to be some folks
who get displaced very summarily and so
managing this transition in both groups
is a must and right now the the question
is how can you Coke some folks being
like look guys you're going to be okay
but AI is going to start doing this
Lifting for us or this surgery for us
and you're not you're not going to
starve to death you'll be fine and then
also go to the folks whose work is made
irrelevant very
quickly this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without Express
VPN is like changing while leaving your
window wide open gross you might not
have anything to hide but why give
random creeps a chance to invade your
privacy that's why I use expressvpn it's
super easy you hit a button and then you
just beam in best of all you know no one
can see what you're doing no big tech
companies no ad companies no other
companies why use expressvpn when you go
online it is just you and your surfing
no one can see it you know it's the way
to go because a bunch of big companies
say say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
yangang so I get the idea that we're
going to have uh ingrained um biases and
uh self- motivation keeping things the
way they have and that's always been the
case right um I'm sure it falls
eventually I mean there will be a point
where when you see that human surgeon
coming at you and you say oh no no no I
do not want that human touching me you
know I don't know how much coffee they
had if they had a fight with a boyfriend
or girlfriend last night I want the
robot I want the robot that has seen
this surgery a million times and cost
you know 100 times cheaper I want it
doing the surgery and so the question
becomes um you know we're going to have
to be datadriven uh Evolution and I
think we're going to see it's not going
to be a little fuzzy it's going to be
the AI is making the right
diagnosis um you know 99 times of 100
compared to the uh to the human and one
of the biggest problems is humans make a
lot of mistakes yep I mean your your
entire uh had a fight with their partner
or uh got drunk or something I mean that
stuff's real you know it's not like our
physicians are super human or what not I
mean like they they're I mean they they
have problems and their problems do not
keep them from coming in and operating
on
us whatever the case may be so so we're
gonna have I hope the cost of living is
going to demonetize I mean it has
tremendously right uh but we don't we
don't count those things that have
demonetized we don't count the fact that
our Communications are world class as
good as the president of Nations had you
know decades ago and it's free video
conferencing on FaceTime or Zoom I mean
that's insane we don't count that we
don't count the all of the free
entertainment we have the free knowledge
even free AI we have uh but the things
that we do pay uh for there's going to
be demonetization pressures I agree
Peter and in many ways so someone once
described me um in a flattering way uh
as wanting to be America's wet blanket
uh like I just want everyone to chill
out while we make this set of
Transitions and right now Americans are
getting the opposite of more
chill shall we shall we say yeah uh
we're getting we're getting yeah we're
getting stressed down inflamed
uh and polarized and uh scarcity is
taking over and more and more insecurity
as Jazelle put it um so I see my role as
trying to make it so that we can
actually enjoy the Bounty of this uh
amazing time to be yes it's
extraordinary you know one of the other
ideas that one of my a360 members um has
spoken about I think you've spoken about
this as well is basic living as a
service you know a community where for
250 bucks month uh you get uh housing
internet water food what else do you
want to throw in there right so a fixed
cost and and entertainment entertainment
sure um which I I love that idea because
at scale this is what technology can do
it can it can give us um a constantly
demonetizing meeting all our basic needs
and allowing you to earn a living that
allows you to put away money and
reinvest it yeah I joked Peter at one
point it's like we have to enter the era
of terrible artwork um because we just
have people who are able to chill out
and paint terrible paintings or whatever
the heck it is you know what I
mean yeah some of them will be awesome
I'm sure but terrible yeah s Guru um I
don't know if you know s Guru um uh he I
was on stage with him years ago in St
Petersburg and um we had dinner
afterwards and he said something that
has never left me he says uh uh
technology allows Humanity to finally
take a vacation from survival right he
he's totally right and we've been
operating under this resource constraint
mindset and institutional setup and
everything else where at zero sum and
we're about to hit a point where a lot
of these Goods uh will have essentially
zero marginal cost and then what do you
do in an era of abundance what does that
become uh we're not set up for it and in
many ways I feel like the challenge is
trying to prepare us for abundance in a
time when scarcity actually
unfortunately is the lived experience of
many of our our fellow Americans and
humans agreed I mean one of the um last
points I want to touch base with you on
here cuz I think it's fundamental to uh
solving Ubi in an actual functional way
is that of purpose right I think um as
as living a human
experience as a biological uh uh
individual uh we need
purpose um and just you know surviving
is not that and just being given money
isn't that any thoughts on on this you
know um when I was running for president
Peter I I had visions of of an American
Exchange program where when you were
graduating from high school you'd go to
another part of the country and live
with a family who by the way would send
their kids someplace else too so they'd
probably be nice to you maybe you'd even
trade what a great way of creating
globalization and peace right yeah so
then you'd be like hey when when someone
says something negative about the those
folks in uh the red or blue Zone you'd
be like I actually hung out with them
and they're perfectly fine and they're
they're just like us uh like uh I had
Notions of various types of national
competitions not because it necessarily
had economic value but because people
need structure purpose fulfillment goals
Community uh what if you were to rewind
to an earlier point in American Life um
maybe your church or religious group
served a particular role in your life um
now that has gotten replaced
unfortunately by this is going to hurt
you in your heart but it's been replaced
uh by politics in some uh
so some some people's lives uh so so we
we do need to imbue more communities
with the sense of structure purpose
fulfillment goals uh and one of the big
misconceptions about me has been that I
was somehow unmindful of that I mean um
I I'm or I mean I like to work honestly
now I'm very very fortunate where I get
to do very very meaningful purposeful
work and genuinely feel like hey if I
weren't here um something wouldn't get
done so that's a good feeling and that
the goal has to be to try and make it so
that more people have that feeling and
even if it's not something society-wide
like maybe you or or I am working on it
can be something as simple as today I'm
going to be very important to helping my
neighbor you know clear their garage or
care for their children or what have you
yeah one of the things that people um
hopefully realize is a lot of the jobs
not all but a lot of the jobs that
Robotics and AI will take are jobs that
were not the jobs people dreamed of
doing when they were kids right um they
didn't dream of being a waiter or
cleaning apartment buildings or whatever
it might be um but that was the job that
you could get to put food on your table
or get insurance for your family and so
the question really is fine let Tech
take take those jobs that are dull
dangerous or dirty you know and um how
do we enable that individual now to
level up to what they dreamed about um
how do we allow people to dream into a
bigger purpose and I think AI as their
co-pilot to help them educate themselves
and do things they didn't think they
could do um is critical and and I think
it's almost we have to split the split
what you do for a living to make money
separate for what you do for a purpose
yeah and and one thing Peter that you
suggested just now is that there is a
distinction between how men and women or
boys and girls experience uh this
phenomena where uh and and Studies have
borne this out by the way that if you
have an idol man um they volunteer less
than an employed man even though they
have more time um and their consumption
of uh drugs and gambling and some other
things go
up and and so the sense of purpose and
usefulness that you're describing uh is
vital to stav off um both personal and
community
self-destruction and one of the things
that Americans are experiencing at
higher levels unfortunately are those
things uh deaths of Despair continue to
to Rise um and there's an asymmetry in
terms of how men and women uh
are fairing uh in Contemporary American
life where now uh only 40% of incoming
college students are men as an example
um and so there has to be a massive
investment in things that help men in
particular find uh A A Way Forward um in
the absence of these kinds of measures
many men will go down dark rabbit holes
and Roots um and that's where the
negativity takes over yeah and and
unfortunately it is also the case for
younger men and their teens when
hormones hit um and they're not fighting
the Lions on the savanas of Africa yes
and and this is something I feel very
deeply where uh you know again I've been
very fortunate but I remember as a young
man when I started a company and did not
work out and my Asian parents frankly
pretended to their friends that I was
still a lawyer and doing
well that um you know you you you feel
um like this challenge to your selfworth
U now I was again very fortunate that in
my case I joined another startup um and
then which is what what makes America
great yeah yeah that's what makes
America great but but there there are
lots of uh young men in particular who
don't have this set of opportunities and
then for them um they kind of shrink
inward I'm also the parent of two young
boys so it's one reason why I feel
this yeah oh yeah so you you feel this
too yeah um and uh you know I mean
instinctively like your kids will be
fine my kids will be fine one of my boys
on the autism spectrum has particular
challenges but I I see uh American boys
uh in different circumstances and a lot
of them um you know if they don't find a
productive direction it'll turn inward
in ways that are not positive yeah I
want to thank you Andrew for Having the
courage to run for for president it is
uh something I will never do uh not for
me but uh not even in an independent
primary where people can vote on their
smartphones Peter where you can actually
talk STS uh if if if logic uh actually
rules um um okay it's a nonzero but it's
still it's I'd rather spend my time
solving the world's biggest problem in
many ways my goal will be to make it so
that awesome people like you have a
higher chance of thr out in the ring
than is currently the case currently I
would totally uh you know get it all
right but listen I love the idea of Mark
hbin versus Tony Robbins uh versus Kim
Kardashian as on the on the uh
independent uh Spectrum for election it
would be a fun fun election I mean we
could actually pay for the entire thing
with just the reality TV rights and we
would run the table Peter genuinely
because so many Americans would look up
I mean two-thirds of Americans while an
alternative to the two-party system if
you had that Battalion everyone would be
like okay we're totally doing
that we would we we would win I mean you
know and this is something we should be
building towards as quickly as possible
yeah yeah well thank you for your moon
shots my friend just to remind folks
again it is uh to uh reinvent and fix
the uh democracy no small Challenge and
then to help uh birth Ubi as a program
that is recognized understood and rolled
out um not just here United States but
through an example in the United States
I think around the world uh I'm looking
forward to a time when uh kids are
dreaming of the types of moonshots they
had when I was a kid right being an
astronaut go to the Moon um and uh Moon
shots that really make the world a
better place where do we find you on
social media Andrew uh well what a
vision Peter uh will fight alongside you
to make it real for kids around the
world you can find me at andrewyang.com
Andrew Yang and most social media
platforms or you can go to forward
party.com but let's actually build a
version of the future we know is
possible it's not going to happen
without us I love it and watch out for
uh for Andrew's uh new book the last
election uh and remember the hero is
Mark cubin
um but don't tell but don't tell Mark
that uh pal uh thank thank you for your
vision and I'm going to help spread your
word cuz I believe in what you're saying
it makes a heck of a lot of sense well
thank you Peter it's it's about
abundance my
friend